we're taking a tribia quiz today oh no
play together you can compete against
each other comp I kind of want to she
wants to compete I guess we compete I
know the answers ga's down challenge
accepted it's me and Tom we're doing
teams yeah yeah yeah and as long as we
together get more than you we win how
dare hi BuzzFeed I'm Rachel zler I'm Tom
BL I'm Josh Rivera and we are the cast
of the new Hunger Games The Ballad of
song birds and snakes today we are here
with BuzzFeed to test our knowledge on
the original Hunger Games and how are
you going to do you know how you going
to do it's a competition just before
this she was just bragging about so you
better all three of the original books
are under my chair because I was reading
them before we started that's cheating
um no I didn't know that this is what we
were doing it's not an open test you
would know a lot you know a lot about
cheating at games wouldn't you see the
movie Katniss's nickname is Girl on Fire
what I wonder is petas H boy on fire boy
Genius Baker Boy and lover boy all right
this one's easy I'm going I clicked
lover boy because that's what glimmer
calls him in the games it's it's boy on
fire I'm going with boy Genius psych I
clicked lover boy wait mind game I went
for the funny option got it wrong all
right now it's on in The Hunger Games
what score does Peter get after his
training session 6 8 9 and 12 okay these
are actually getting harder now for some
reason I remember six we all just saw
the first one I know exactly what oh you
do actually I do 3 two 1 Click oh I was
wrong I put what did you put I put six I
eight it's eight good job guys cuz I
remember their numbers going around
their faces my favorite is that
Elizabeth Banks is every drink it goes
we can work with that what is Katniss's
favorite color orange purple blue and
green I'm about to click I clicked my
answer already you already clicked so
catness cat kiss kiss K from a rose can
be purple go for it go for it you're
wrong I thought green was too on the
nose cuz like the forest know I clicked
purple I thought it's green because of
the forest is orange though yeah and she
wood Superior Color like a a woodland
nymph of the Forest right all right
moving
on in Catching Fire which of these
tribute pairings was from District 8
Bight and Joanna Mason wolf and C IA
chaff and Ceda or Brutus and inoar these
are all book accurate but yeah I don't
even remember all the I want to say
because of her relevance to the story
Joanna it's Joanna but I don't actually
know do we get fired retroactively if we
get all these wrong Franc is Francis is
waiting outside the door we're refiling
the whole thing shall we yeah I've got a
hunch oh God you get it wrong what did
you say I said Joanna because of what I
just explained to you CH and is it chafe
chafe isn't right I call Cha isn't right
should said Brutus and and abaria cuz my
my buddy had a car that he named Brutus
oh Joanna's from district 7 so it's wolf
and Cecilia from District eight8 okay
during the 75th annual Hunger Games the
arena is set up like o' clock Tick Tock
which of these threats happens at 3:00
the options are mut monkeys Jabba Jays
blood rain or poisonous fog these are
amazingly difficult good for you I have
no clue you
remember you guys psycho at what time
the lightning struck it's daytime for
the jabber Jays and daytime for the
blood rain so it has to be one of those
two we're working together so smart I
wasn't even I think it's the jabber Jays
assuming that the game start at like
noon but I don't remember makes you
assume they start at you assume they
start at noon I don't know it's a clock
and a clock goes like this beginning 12
seems like a reasonable time to s in put
on their suits get have time to give
coffee a little light brunch yeah yeah
it's important you got to be fed to
fight to the death I'm going for it
sorry blood rain I'm clicking wait no
it's
not oh no we all got it wrong again in
mocking
J what is the capital used to hijack
peta's
mind electric shock jabber Jays tracker
Jacker Venom nightlock berries I feel
like I know this one I don't we I don't
know click on on one yeah what three two
one oh it's tracker Jacker Venom track
Jack that was the first one I said
Electric Shot doesn't doesn't she
hit but that's yeah she it comes back
around cuts down the yeah that's my
favorite part of the original Stanley 2
like staring down the camera going
powerful hallucination which annual
Hunger Games did phix wife Annie win
Annie Crest a great character by the way
the 61st the 65th the 70th or the 73r
the 73rd is right before the first movie
I don't think it could be that recent
cuz they're much older than her I would
say it's either 65th or 70th but I don't
you're side eyeing so hard Jos is like
answer I feel like she probably won
quite a while before like the 73rd or
78th would be too soon oh so let's
should we all as a united front say 65 I
already guessed did you get it right all
right 3 2
1 it's the 70th it's 70th oops did you
click that sorry I'm not doing well I'm
doing terribly everybody had so much
faith in me and I you had so much faith
in oh my God this one's about ours
finally in The Ballad of song birds and
snakes I hope we get this right Tigress
men's Coro shirt what are the buttons
made out of melted down I misclicked and
I was the options are melted down gold
coins copper pipe pieces tesse from
floor tiles Onyx gems from the
Grandmom's necklace it's Tess
T Tess would you Tess I got it t because
we have a really a really gorgeous shot
of Tom like we do we have it it makes it
into the film and Fran has shot this
really beautiful moment where where it
happens I got three out of eight correct
I know the answers you got three yeah I
got four I got four as well how did we
did it eight out of eight yeah a so
actually because we're we're just like
collecting our points against you it's
we got eight and you got three yeah so
it's embarrassing I am embarrassed of
who I am should
be thank you BuzzFeed um thanks BuzzFeed
for that the ballad of song birds and
snakes is in movie theaters now get your
tickets see you
[Music]
there